après avoir battu mika sur son jeu de
prédilection roquettes ligue n'était pas
de la chance n'était pas de la chance
tout le personnel car ils sont de retour
pour la finale devant question mika va
t'il reperdre et craquer son slip une
nouvelle fois à l'arête nous le sont ses
choix
tu vas devoir oublier mais ça arrête de
rire oh
you de mon discussions durent sont avec
mika pour la finale rocade les mangas
c'est parti on a tous les deux pas joué
depuis d'autres affrontements avaient un
choix d'ailleurs on va au nom au nom ça
commence tellement mal non
au nom encore comment tu peux avoir
avantage sur ça s'est passé par amour
est confiant obata non non non non non
non non non mais non allez tiens allez
tiens oui c'est le but pour lucas ocha
aux trembles ont transité à j'ai le
coeur qui m'a vite j'ai vraiment
l'impression d'être devant mille
personnes non ou oui
yes non en tout cas je te remercie pour
tous les conseils que tu m'as donné que
je mette en pratique pour se battre dans
cette vidéo me casser le mythe fait de
8,6 trop parlé il m'a défoncé les trois
brebis cas il reste quatre minutes cède
rien d c'est ma chance voilà c'était
très court
un sketch
à suivre pêche de vigne vite remis de
mise et les rythmes à 4 à rien n'est
perdu il reste dix secondes ah oui tiens
au nom a bavé pour faire le match
par contre tu crois que tu vas mettre je
te mets un retard à 0 pour mai car on
avait dit en trois points en faisant des
vidéos en 3d combattons style outside
j'ai pas la tâche facile jour en chef
doit vous changer tout ce qui est
engagement favorable de la part de mika
voilà là on est bien
c'est facile engagement d'engagement non
c'est pas ça ohlala allez vous m'avez vu
quitter deux fois mais non mais non sans
la sas à partir du rail alors ok j'avais
quitté de boîte olala sais pas c'est
l'un des plus beaux buts de roquettes
je vais l'envoyer au chef d'antenne oui
il ya un silence dans la pièce mais non
il va la mettre sur des questions sur
deux questions je vais bien je sais
c'est beau non
j'ai deux de ses séries non non non non
non non non ça me désole c'est ça votre
[ __ ]
oh oh non j'ai pas allier
sa mère à chaud c'est la débandade
mika vient de gagner deux games des
larmes ont coulé sur le visage les
essais chez j'ai pris ma baguette comme
ça j'ai fait c'est charles la seule arme
assez d'espagnols
c'est lui qui gagne celle là a tout
gagné mais qu'as tu es d'accord on va
faire un pacte du centre pour témoigner
de temps à grains une barrière de
protection
ça touche 10 les moins atteints il ya un
démon qui va arriver dans la savane et
ouest france et non
supra
gaza
mec mais franchement elle est belle elle
est belle cette belle elle est belle
elle peinait en ag à gg franchement
c'est le beau jeu
bonjour
non
non non
c'était quoi la vie
au matin chez g
en ange et gémit kg je suis naïve voire
trop un bon flic est un [ __ ] ça va
être très dur les gens
[ __ ] le soutien de rafik est avec nous
et je le déçois minute après minute
on laisse
oh
aux 3 3 le petit dieu il élargit les lie
les lives et la c ie au non j'aime bien
le petit vieux deux roues quelques clics
ta mère mais la roue a tourné aux dents
longues est beau il a fait un geste qui
le disqualifie y quoi la marque un but
alors j'avais plus la manette dans les
mains on a gagné c'était dans les salles
en replay replay du début de la vidéo
alors commencer par contient une règle
qu'il faut que tu saches si tu marques
un but alors que je n'ai plus la manette
dans les mains tu est disqualifié c'est
compris on l'avait quitté au montage où
on a donc gagné sellerie plein plus gros
tubes à gagner la finale
sur cette vidéo vers savoir regarder
merci d'avoir souscrit on a gagné parce
qu'il n'a pas respecté la règle merci
d'être passé me casser coûtera frites
pas
ans